Speaker 1: Let's go to J.W. are from Atlanta,
Georgia. J.W. Ah, welcome.
Speaker 3: Great to be here again.
I was going to ask. I guess my general question
was how much I think of how to phrase this, how,
how what's the right what's the what's the right
balance of how much of how much attention we
should be giving to this whole thing regarding
Trump and the investigation? Because although,
although he's not as much of an although he is not
as much of an active threat as he was like, say, a
year or a year or two when there was a of getting
when there was a chance of getting reelected.
There is still there is still the possibility that
we might as well like just blow him off, ignore
it, pretend, but just act as though he's not an
issue anymore. So, like, what's the right balance
we should be? What's the right balance to strike?
Speaker 1: We'll listen. If it's not made clear,
it has to be made clear that what Trump did is
humiliatingly criminal and unacceptable. Because
if everybody just stays quiet about it and doesn't
talk about the fact that, you know, he's got dumps
of documents all over his apartment, then it
actually makes it more plausible that voters will
vote for him again in 2024. They really need to
be brutally humiliated into not even considering
supporting the guy in 2024. Now, I know that there
are Republicans who are saying, Oh, the Mar a Lago
rate is the best thing that could have happened to
Trump. I've seen no real evidence of that so far.
Speaker 3: Well, not not so far and hopefully
not too far away. Also, I only have one question.
Speaker 1: Well, it depends what
it is. Let's hear the second one.
Speaker 3: Do you think that there is a
chance that better man could potentially
screw up the lead he has over over over Dr.
Oz in the Senate race in Pennsylvania. So far,
things look good. But do you think there are?
Do you think that there is a chance that they
might finally screw this up in their base?
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, listen, you can
always screw it up. It's looking very solid for
Fetterman right now, but of course, he could screw
it up. Let's just hope it doesn't happen.
Speaker 3: Oh, of course not. I mean,
I'm not saying that I think he is going
to. I think he is in a very good place,
but not like. Put it this way, he is winning,
but he has not won yet. Absolutely. I,
I just. Yes. And I. I just hope that he that
the fact that his campaign, which so far has
done a pretty decent job, continues to keep
it up and doesn't and doesn't, I guess, blow
the blow of a 3 to 1 lead that they have so far.
Speaker 1: Yes, I have not seen that. It's three,
two, one. But I appreciate the phone call very,
very much. I believe what you're referring to
is that he's estimated to have a 75% chance of
winning, but not that he's going to win 75 to 25